okay let's go what day is it it's woke
Wednesday let's get to whatever woke
Wednesday's about today it is so crazy
how Republicans just believe Donald
Trump I mean look at this insane thing
he said tonight they've done is they've
gone after opponents so that if you
become president or some other job but
if you become president and you don't
like somebody or if somebody's beating
you by 10 15 or 20 points like we're
doing with crooked Joe Biden let's
indict the
mother oh my like Donald Trump is trying
to claim that since he's running for
president he's being indicted and
Republicans believe him did you hear
that Applause they just mindlessly clap
at anything he says like I can't tell if
this kid is being ironic and it's going
to come out that he's a conservative and
he's like he's doing a parody of a lib
or if he really if he's really shocked
and
befuddled that conservatives might
believe that the U historic prosecution
of the former president opposition
leader might might be somewhat political
keep going Here's a thought Republicans
and just hear me out for a second maybe
Trump did it you know maybe he committed
crimes maybe he's not being indicted
because he's running for president maybe
he actually did steal classified
documents which there's a lot of
evidence to support maybe he did commit
Rico in Georgia which there's evidence
to support maybe he did enter into a
criminal conspiracy to defraud the
United States which there's evidence to
support maybe he just did it like
there's so much evidence against Donald
Trump and then Trump just says no it's
political well they argument I mean the
RICO thing is so insane that the first
example he used is a great one says
maybe he did have the classified
documents okay first of all he was the
president of the United States he had
the authority to declassify at
will whatever he wanted to but second of
all the evidence that his prosecution
would be political rather than merely
criminal or legal is that Hillary
Clinton who had no authority to
declassify documents at will committed
the very same crime in a more egregious
way because she mishandled those
classified documents and stored them on
a Home Server that could be hacked and
almost certainly was hacked by our
enemies abroad unlike Trump who only had
physical copies that were locked in a
closet which obviously could not be
hacked by our enemies abroad and Hillary
was not prosecuted even though the FBI
even though James Comey recognized that
what she did was deeply
wrong and almost certainly illegal and
she wasn't prosecuted and Trump is
having the book thrown at him for for a
lesser version of the same crime that
almost certainly is not even a crime
because he was the president of the
United States and not merely a secretary
of state like Hillary right there in
your first example you've undercut your
argument and all these Republicans
believe him like do you know how much of
a cult you have to be in to believe him
when there's hundreds of pages of
evidence against him do you know how
insane you have to be to believe that
guy I guarantee that not a single person
in that room or any Maga Republican who
says he's innocent has has read the
indictment I'd put anything on it I
really would you would be wise not to
believe a single word that comes out of
Donald Trump's mouth because that's a
man with everything to lose of course
he's going to say whatever he has to say
to keep himself out of prison I guess
he's missing the point which
is he doesn't seem to understand what a
political persecution is I'm telling
mother persecution be it through
prosecution or through any other means a
political prosecution in this case would
would not necessarily mean that the
person didn't do anything wrong when
Stalin would have his show trials it it
it wasn't the case that the people he
brought up on show trials had not done
anything wrong it's that the charges
were trumped up when When Vladimir Putin
jails his
political opposition leader Alex Alexi
Naval it it's not because navali has
never done anything wrong it's that the
charges are trumped up and he's being
selectively prosecuted when Desh duu was
sent to that halfway house for giving a
little extra money through his family
members to his college friend Wendy long
who never had a snowballs chance in hell
of winning the senate seat in New York
it's not that he didn't do anything
wrong it's just that no one ever gets
prosecuted for that unless you make the
the highest grossing documentary ever in
history that so happens to be about the
sitting US president and then and then
the president's goons come after you and
send you to
jail that's what that's about so look on
some of these charges on some of these
accusations Trump is obviously
completely innocent the Bergdorf Goodman
depart store rape story from the 1990s
is obviously completely insane on the
issue of did he have classified
documents he he obviously did have the
classified documents I'm not convinced
that was a crime at all since he was the
president but yeah he had that the
question is why is he being prosecuted
for it you don't need to read the
indictment to even to know that or any
of the many indictments against him to
to ask that question why is he being
prosecuted for this when people who have
committed much worse versions of the
same crimes have not been but these
young men they don't know they don't
know they got to they got to grow older
they got to take off their Anakin
Skywalker shirts and you know put on put
on the vestments of wisdom and
education